Is the new.
This is a new genre of TV show of the
real guy versus the guy playing in the
movie. Well, I want to see doctors
against guys who played a doctor.
I only see astronauts against guys
who would take her an astronaut.
I want to see it all
from a movie versus real dinosaur
versus chicken. I want to say,
isn't that what Mark Wahlberg sign if
he was on the plane, spy versus city.
Did he really say that though?
That's what everybody says.
I never heard him say that. It's
funny, funny something to think.
It's a crazy thing to think.
You know who knows what the fuck you
would do if you thought that you were just
going to land somewhere.
You know?
That's the idea is that you knew what
was going to happen before it happened.
Nobody knows. Well, while that shit's
going down, someone's got box cutters,
they were holding the waitress. They're
holding a stewardess by the neck. Like,
yeah, you don't know what
the fuck's happening. You
have no idea what's going on.
We're afraid to move and you know, I'm
sure that a lot of people would step up,
but you,
you know,
it could potentially cost that person
their life and then when the plane lands,
that person's dead when they may
be, if you don't know, right.
You don't know the actual scenario.
Now obviously we know it was a horrible
thing and you should do whatever you can
to stop them because they're going
to kill everybody no matter what.
But back then you didn't know when.
If someone just took the plane and landed
in the stewardess, he would be like,
glad I didn't do anything. He jumped
up and he cut her face off. You know,
it's like in, in those moments when
you don't know what's going to happen.
To said I was on that plane.
Okay.
If with my kids and when
it went down like it did,
that would have been a lot of blood in
that first class cabin. Then me saying,
okay, we're going to land
somewhere safely. Don't worry.
Well that seat, I see where
he's coming from. Right.
He's got a, he's got kids that he loves.
You've got a family that he loves,
he wouldn't have sat still.
That's what he's saying.
Yeah. That's what he's saying.
And in his mind,
he probably has that conviction.
Even if it meant the thing running
everybody's life. Would you, you know,
would it work if it didn't work?
Like what did they have?
Do you know what they have? They have
a box cutter. They have anything else?
How many of them are there?
You don't know. Like is
anybody going to back you up?
Does anybody else know how to fight? You
know, you could get fucked up. You could,
you could step up thinking you're
Billy Badass and this guy is,
I'm the trainers who smashes your face
in and cuts you up with a box cutter that
could happen to, it still pulls his
belt off of the planet. It could.
Who the fuck knows Matt? The, that's
why there's professionals, right?
That's where there's professional,
those air marshals that can assess the
situation and figure out and obviously,
you know,
they weren't either they weren't there
on that plane or they couldn't help.
I sure was thinking about if I was in
that position, you know, how could you,
I mean, who the fuck knows
what you would do? Well,
since I look like I'm on the other team,
I would've said my friend
fucking it up. Come
on, get up and do your,
I'm like not part of the team
Dave, do your phone. Fuck man.
Yeah, you'll be, you know.
Have you ever been so scared
that your frozen instant
for a second? Oh yeah. Yeah.
I mean you can't know what the right thing
to do is and the wrong thing could be
so catastrophic.
Great.
It was not really good as
far as to say like that.
He's making announcements on the
plane and this is all happening.
Like we're landing,
say like he's now the pilot in the movies.
Right.
That's true.
The movie you get to grant the intercom
at the end didn't go thanks for flying
so-and-so air.
Sometimes you say things like that cause
that's how you feel and you don't think
about how other people
are going to perceive it.
That's what I would assume
that that statement is. It's
kind of how he felt like,
fuck that.
I'm landing this fucking plane.
I'm going to kill this fucking terrorists.
That's what he told his kids one night.
The problem is you're saying that to
billions of people and billions of people
hear that and they go, what? And then
all of these people get to assess your,
your statement,
whether or not it has any makes any sense.
Like what are you going to do? You can
kick everybody's ass. Okay, okay, sure.
I know a lot of dudes who, if they
were there and you tried to do that,
you'd get smashed. Right?
Like they're scary.
People in this world is holding
weapons on him. I would assume.
If you're ready to die like that,
you have a very strange kind of conviction
to if you know you're ready to die
and you know how to fight like oof Jesus.
I don't mean who knows,
but it's like, okay,
the idea that you would have to think
about it, that's what's really terrifying.
What do you mean? The idea that
you would have to think like,
what do I do if something is someone does
hijack a plane? We all think that, yeah.
Every, every situation. Now there's
that what we do do, what do you do?
What do you do? I mean, so you
hear people run and they survived.
Then you people would run and get shot
down and they go to the wrong way. Well,
anytime a tragedy like that happen,
she's like, what the fuck? Horrific.
Random set of sequences and you're in
the wrong spot and you'll do the right.
Heroic.
How about how many people must do the
heroic thing and then they die anyway?
You never know about it. Oh, for sure.
I wonder what Uncle Steve
did in that situation. Yeah.
Yeah.